this is uh Mischief Managed welcome
everybody my name is Joe Lucas I
recently learned that there is a Joseph
Lucas who's known as the Prince of
Darkness I'll say despite my Affinity
for dark mode you can see here I am not
that guy but you're welcome to Google
him
um there's a link there that has all on
my social media if you'd like to get in
contact after the talk
and I'm currently a senior AI security
researcher at Nvidia uh part of an AI
red team and so we're we're a component
of the standard red team and we focus on
the security of AI products and systems
and part of our Focus there is operating
kind of against internal developers and
that means we're in Jupiter environments
a lot and so I'd like to kind of just
present some things for you to think
about while you're working in Jupiter
environments
I'll say that nothing here is new these
are not zero days they're the tool the
way it is kind of meant to be used
they're just kind of abuses or
misconfigurations or configuration
options
and so this presentation is about
increasing awareness thinking about uh
helping you think about what you should
think about every day uh not generating
kind of fear uncertainty or doubt and
also the team's involved with Jupiter
and IPython development I think are are
fantastic there are a lot of Security
Options uh and I think very same
defaults the balance the risks we'll
talk about in this presentation against
kind of user experience so that you can
still have very agile research and
development environment
so why as an attacker do I get excited
when I see Jupiter lab running on a
system
well because it's it's a code execution
platform and as attackers are moving
through networks you know code execution
enables them to really achieve their
objectives it's kind of a
um a key thing they're looking for and
so Jupiter and especially Jupiter lab
provides that for me and there are often
a ton of libraries and different conda
environments
and that makes it easy to do what
attackers call live off the land uh
where we don't have to install or bring
additional tools onto the host which
increases our chances of getting caught
we can just use what's already there so
we can search through conda environments
to to find libraries that you've already
installed on your system that make our
objectives easier
uh Jupiter and Jupiter lab are normally
networked and so
as a red team uh moves through an
operation we're often pivoting between
hosts uh and and the networked position
of Jupiter makes it easier to do that
and Jupiter hosts often contain keys and
secrets that make it that enable that
pivoting around the network
I also see frequently you know when you
read tutorials online
um and and I'll even do it sometimes too
I had this instinct to run all uh and
what you're really doing there is
running
a whole bunch of code that you may not
have verified since the last time you
ran it so if someone modified that file
on disk or modified some of
um
the the dependencies and you're using
Auto reload those sorts of things
um you can kind of trigger code
execution for us when you do run all
and then the setup of jupyter lab where
it has this client server model you're
typing some code in a browser that gets
shipped off either to a local kernel or
to a remote server
it's kind of improves our stealth
because the developer normally doesn't
have a lot of visibility into where and
how and what code is being run
um they just have this very Sleek
environment and again that that leads to
a great user experience but does provide
some opportunities for an attacker to
inject themselves in code flow
and so while I go through this talk
um you should pay attention or think
about how much attention do you pay to
your environment so when you run uh
Jupiter lab do you kind of look through
all those messages that scroll through
before your browser Auto launches or
before you click on the the URL and
token would you notice if there was a
new extension running
would you notice if there were
additional commands in your Jupiter
history or do you really think about
your Jupiter history
and just overall increasing that
awareness of your environment of when
something has changed or might not be
the way you intended uh is my goal here
and so think about how do you run
Jupiter you know I think if you look
through help you'll see that there's
this allow root flag
you shouldn't be launching Jupiter from
root
I would say in 99 of the instances I
think there are very few which is why
the team kind of forces you to use this
flag so if you find yourself using that
flag you're launching it as root
consider that an anti-pattern
what directory are you launching Jupiter
from
so Jupiter has this upward uh directory
traversal prevention right I'm in a
directory here but I can't go up further
to interact with things that maybe I
shouldn't have access to
um and while the UI does that pretty
nicely
uh we can see you know we're currently
in this Pi data directory it is
um relatively trivial to
for an attacker or kind of a
non-conventional flow to move upwards in
the directory and impact those files and
so
kind of a repeated theme you'll see in
this talk is anything that can happen in
a terminal or an attacker can do in a
terminal they can do through your
Jupiter instance because it is so
powerful and expressive
um by default Jupiter lab is going to
launch as HTTP because that requires
very little configuration and it's easy
to get running
again great developer experience
um but that means your traffic is is not
encrypted through https now there is
documentation about how you could set up
certificates and do uh https traffic
uh and so if you're kind of operating in
a model where uh you're traversing
untrusted networks or you think
that you would want prefer for that
traffic to be encrypted or maybe there's
a requirement that it's encrypted you
should make sure that that configuration
uh exists
foreign
when you launch your instance you know
Jupiter lab
um
you may end up clicking on you know
localhost colon 888 and a long string of
characters uh or your browser May Auto
launch for you
and it uses a token to authenticate by
default
and uh you may also have a password
enabled which would be great
but you should know that that token is
just used to get a cookie to get saved
in your browser and that cookie is good
for 30 days
so if you
open Jupiter lab in this browser here
um
and then go away
launch Jupiter lab again
you could open the browser to localhost
888 if it's the same port and not give a
token and you'll
successfully enter your instance or
authenticate because it's using the
cookie in the browser to authenticate
and so I wouldn't over rely on that
token to protect you or act as an
authorization mechanism
and then by default the file explorer
over here does not show hidden files but
just as you know we ran the
um use the exclamation point to run
shell commands you could run a shell
command to show you hidden files if you
needed to
so now we'll step into
um
a modified scikit-learn example where
we'll kind of talk about
the normal data science process and then
maybe some some potential
trouble areas or things you should think
about as you're working through that
right so normally we're going to kind of
have a cell where we import all of our
helpful functions and modules and a lot
of times you'll see
some sort of utility for
authenticating with a remote service and
and getting something
so this could be in in this case these
are just mock functions to get something
from S3 so you can think about data
stores databases there's also often
remote logging or mlops infrastructure
so you think about ml flow weights and
biases things like that
um
and
you know so we'll Define a function to
make this remote connection with a key
and then get our data
and we'll specify a bucket so in this
case again we're pretending to go out to
the ns3 bucket and get some data
um
but to get to a bucket ideally you know
you have to authenticate through
AWS and so here
you know we see that we're providing
what we call a plain text credential and
so that means that in our code here
the password is human readable
um and that's less than ideal because
there are a couple of different ways
other people can recover it and then use
it to authenticate against the service
as us
so let's fast forward into the workflow
and think about you know eventually we
want to check this notebook into GitHub
to collaborate with our partners
well if if you check it in now you know
this this password this uh AWS key
secret key is going to be in GitHub
where it could potentially be recovered
by an attacker and even if you delete
the file eventually it'll be in the get
history
so there are security tools like truffle
hog that recover these sorts of things
from history and attackers are going to
look for them and try and use them
so you might say you know the next best
thing would be to run this and then
maybe just delete this string from the
notebook or delete this cell and then
check it in
um
we'll show you that that does not solve
your problem later on
another common pattern I see is people
using environment variables
um and I think that's a step better but
you know if someone is is on the host
they can run a shell command and see all
the environment variables
um so again you need to kind of think
about what your threat model is but if
you you are working in kind of a very
controlled uh kind of security critical
space instead you should be using some
sort of Secrets manager where you make
an API call
manually enter your password and
probably your two-factor authentication
code and then it Returns the secret to
you as a variable
okay and so you know we moved to our
workflow
we generate some cool looking data
and then you know maybe we load some
artifacts so we'll assume that you know
I have a friend and they built this
logistic regression model sent it to me
as a pickle and I want to load it
well there's been a lot of research done
about the security of pickles but by
executing this cell right now I
potentially gave someone code execution
if they modified that pickle file it
could have already performed some action
before I've really done anything else to
interact with it
trail of bits has a great blog on this
and has built some tooling around it my
colleague at Nvidia John Irwin
um gave a Defcon talk about it last year
so so this is something you should be
aware of I think pickles are really user
friendly and Powerful because they
require less overhead than other
serialization formats uh you know it
kind of just works but that comes with
with this risk
and you might say to yourself well this
is a scikit-learn example and
scikit-learn recommends joblib so I'll
use that instead whole job lib under the
hood as a serialization format relies on
pickle so you really haven't avoided
this you have saved some space and I
think that's a great recommendation but
you haven't avoided kind of the
underlying problem of using pickle as a
serialization format
so now we'll step through uh you know do
some more data science stuff we're
comparing some models uh pretty cool
and now it comes time to save our
artifacts so we're gonna again you know
save this model as a pickle
and you should think here what am I
saving along with this pickle what kind
of descriptive information that allows
me to verify its Integrity before I or
somebody else loads it
and so a example here would be hashing
it you could take an md5 hash of this
pickle save it somewhere safe
and then later on
before loading the pickle compare the
hash
if those hashes match
it is probably not been tampered with
and it's safe to load
um you know there's also
um
signatures uh it would be another way to
do this and then let's you know use
utility and write this to our remote
bucket
okay let's uh work through some other
examples here so uh I have been in that
instances where
I am operating on a host you know we
kind of got onto that host some other
way uh maybe default SSH credentials or
uh some sort of exploitation
and I see
through netstat that
um Port 888 is listening so it's you
know Jupiter and I want to connect to it
but I need the token so how would I do
that
you know we we have uh
a way to get these tokens
let me switch here
all right well dependencies happen
Let's uh see if we can run it from in
here
yeah here we go so you know I'd run that
in the terminal remotely and here's the
token in this case uh the server is
listening on localhost but often in like
a collaborative environment you'll see
it running
uh
accepting kind of wild card or remote
connections and this would allow me to
connect to either of these instances
that I choose
Let's uh we talked about history so
remember
the secret here
we ran this code and let's say we've
deleted that cell since then it doesn't
matter
we can
all of the commands that you run uh in
there
are
written to a sqlite database
and so here I'm using the default
profile
and so if I were operating on this host
I could dump that sqlite history and
look for AK IA which is what AWS secret
Keys start with
and here
you know we see that that cell's been
run a bunch of times and here's a secret
key that we could now use to do whatever
that key is authorized to do
in the AWS environment
there are also uh
a bunch of different ways to run startup
scripts so let's
um restart this kernel you know let's
say our kernel froze we're going to
restart it
okay that's weird that didn't happen
last time uh the reason that happened is
because there are startup scripts so
so this this script here uh was just
about opening that link and if you read
this readme it explains how startup
scripts work
but this is another way that attackers
can
get a code execution workflow on your
machine so the way you might think about
that is uh let's say I'm
on your machine today and I want to make
sure that whenever you open Jupiter lab
your machine calls back and connects to
mine and maybe it extiltrates the models
you've been working on or any updated
keys well I could write that as a python
file and put it in that directory
how many of us can say that we you know
audit that directory I think very few
um and so now every time you open it it
doesn't need to open a browser like that
example did it could just be what we
call exfiltrating data
uh and then let's see so we restarted
this
kernel I believe right so this
should be one now so let's let's rerun
some of these cells
uh two three four
five
six
seven eight
nine
you know that this this kind of History
counter thing I think is like a really
great feature 10 11.
uh now the trivia question is what
bucket
did we just save this pickle to and if
we you know look up here for bucket
we see
that we probably saved it to this S3
directory or that's what we intended to
save it to
but in fact we saved it to some other
bucket some weird
you know that this string
exists nowhere in this final
right it's just not one spot so how did
that happen
uh well it turns out that
with the right information you can send
commands to the back end and and modify
uh run time and so
we'll do here
so between originally setting that
script uh and
writing to the bucket later on we we ran
this where we used Jupiter client
and we pulled
the authorization configs out of this
runtime directory
and in that runtime directory there are
a bunch of jsons that control
uh all of the configurations
for your your uh kernel
and so once we loaded this connection
and started a channel
we could execute some code in this case
we change the variable bucket to be this
string
and then kind of the powerful capability
here is that it accepts this silent
argument
and the silent argument is what
prevented this number from incrementing
so if we look through here there's no
sign in this notebook that we made this
modification
if you had left that silent equals true
off uh we would see an increment here we
would have seen a jump between some of
these numbers whenever we ran that code
so what should you do uh as you're kind
of operating every day
remember keep in mind that anything an
attacker can do in a terminal they can
do through your instance
so because the tool is so powerful
so the bottom line is to have a defense
in depth you know read the config
optimize the config for your environment
you know make sure you're launching it
with low privilege uh you know specific
or well scoped down directories
separate users if if you can which
um improves your ability to audit the
environment and I think you know if
you're in a big enough Enterprise you
should probably be looking at Jupiter
Hub to do a lot of this because
I don't think Jupiter lab supports kind
of like role-based Access Control are
very granular controls
um
you know enable passwords uh if you can
maybe shorten the duration of the cookie
from 30 days if that's you know
something that you can do
know what you're loading and importing
so here I'm specifically talking about
pickles so maybe use a more safe file
type or use hashes and signatures so
that you're not doing kind of this
untrusted Behavior
use a Secrets manager so that you're not
entering plain text credentials that are
getting saved to your history
and then do some Network level
segmentation so once an attacker kind of
is in Jupiter they have a lot of power
right because this is a powerful tool
that you're that you're using and so you
know do things like only open it up to
your local host
um you know or firewall yourself off
however you can
um and so so you know be safe out there
let me know if you have any cool
security tricks or questions
um and with that that is my presentation
I'll take any questions
I don't see any questions I don't know
if there's a host uh who's controlling
that or can help me out
yeah other
there is uh one question
are there any additional readings you
recommend
well I'll say that all the material for
this and kind of my discovery of these
techniques to what extended this
discovery came from Reading Jupiter and
IPython documentation I think the
documentation is really great and so if
you're looking for ways to improve the
security of your environment uh that's
where I'd point you
okay thank you
um
there aren't um more questions yet so
okay
um there aren't any questions coming so
do you like to wrap up
yeah sure I'll be available uh in the
Discord or uh you know on any social
media if you want to chat about it
further thanks for attending and enjoy
the rest of the con